hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend I'm coming in hot today and
I'll tell you why yeah you suck
oh well I'm just saying I'm concerned
I'm concerned about the future of this
podcast and I think we need to clear the
air a little bit of course I'm joined by
my very nasty uh acerbic assistant son
of obsession Hi and um the always steady
when steadfast Matt Gourley here's the
issue the issue is that
um this potential booking has arisen and
I the reason we started fighting
beforehand is I just said I'm worried
Sona about this podcast this booking
happening because there might be some
issues that's all I'm saying you a don't
normally talk about bookings on the show
before the show happened sure and you
don't like talking about potential
bookings could you because you don't
want to jinx it I know I know that this
goes against my rules but you also know
that I'm a very free-form kind of guy
no no I just
even Blaze like no no wincing you know
that I'm
over here
dinosaur yes probably sure no I don't
know uh and now I've blown who are
guests yeah yeah let's figure out your
references ahead of time yeah no I'm
just saying I happen to know that he
crafted his material Polly uh when I
what I'm trying to say is that I
um I'm very much in touch with the
energy around me I go with the flow I
don't overthink things and that's I
think what's made me a household name
yeah if you're a fan of the cone on the
Barbarian
I don't know I mean who the guy was that
I don't know I was talking about the
Conan movies people love those movies
anyway okay here's what's happening
loyal listeners or people just tuning in
for the first time there's a potential
guest on the horizon it hasn't been
locked down yet
um but uh he wants to do the the podcast
and I've interviewed him several times
or many times in the past on The Late
Night shown always love them and the
problem is there's someone in this room
who's such a super fan
um that I almost worry about this
gentleman's Safety and Security during
the interview mine no oh just stop being
a wise ass for one second okay I want
you to accept the fact that there's a
maybe 50 50 chance that you will be in a
room with Harrison Ford in the near
future and that he might be a guest on
the podcast and you would sit here and
participate in that interview he would
be sitting maybe about I think I'm gonna
say that's about a foot and a half from
you
we can make that a foot if we really no
no no
taking the wheels off these rolly chairs
I don't want you Wheeling over to him
every second and cuddling
um you are
a massive James Bond fan but you also
are a fanatic a Harrison Ford fanatic
yes Star Wars you name it anything
Harrison Ford has done you saw him in
Eugene O'Neill's Iceman Cometh uh in the
audience he was there working on a seat
that was broken uh but I mean you are
you are obsessed with this man Harrison
Ford yeah he's my favorite actor of all
time he's played you know Indiana Jones
and Han Solo two of my favorite
characters he's a carpenter he's Gruff
he suffers no fools I think you're right
you should worry about this yes I'm glad
Sona I think you're gonna be cool oh I'm
gonna be cool yeah you're fine you like
you you like you Sam Harris I love
Harrison Ford but you can control
yourself this is
this is Uncharted Territory you know I'm
a professional I've been around major
Stars uh my whole life what yeah yeah
you haven't been around major Stars your
whole life my father was a
microbiologist you're also bearing the
leader what I meant what I meant was
Major stars in the world of microbiology
oh right right okay yeah yeah people
that have done incredible work on
antibiotic resistance what did you think
oh I'm sorry I thought you meant like
celebrities like TV stars these are
celebrities to me oh I'm sorry okay we
all have to look out for antibiotic
resistance okay use those antibiotics
wisely
names in that field that's what I was
talking about I'm sorry I misunderstood
you
should be able to get it together if
Harrison Ford ends up doing the podcast
he's truly yeah I think when I'm really
really appreciate and Revere someone
like this I will probably end up being a
little bit more reserved and a little
bit more uh on guard because I really
don't want to blow it you know because
if I play my cards right he and I are
leaving Pals oh now let's spend no let's
spend out this scenario a little bit
tell us what's what's what's your what
do you think happens we walk straight
down to Chipotle oh we pick out each
other's meals for each other we try to
size each other up like I bet you're one
of these guys right and I get him and I
nail it and he's like what did you get
him nailed it I just got him a bean and
cheese burrito with some cilantro and a
tomato there's some tomato right a whole
tomato well they cut it up they cut it
up I thought you took a big chance and
said oh and Mr Ford will have a whole
tomato on the side he's gonna eat it
like an apple have you been to Chipotle
what the what the
[Music]
he's like a bear
I hope you know what I'm rooting for
what I hope that you overstepped the
bounds and I hope you blow it in some
way that's maybe even catastrophic for
this podcast but I would live off the
pure joy of that screw-up forever
challenge accepted and Leash uh
Unleashed I think yeah yeah um unclicked
I guess I thought that when I first
heard he was a possibility I thought you
would do something so to keep me and
Matt away from it especially I tried I
tried very hard but he's he said the
only reason that he's doing it is
because of you two oh
he doesn't even
think I'm going to be here
yeah this is my Harrison Ford
I just woke up it's just General Patton
sounds like Clinic I'm gonna kill those
Nazis hey internal patent I'm not Patton
I'm Harrison for uh no he is very funny
he's very dryly funny and very uh very
funny guy and in that sense I think I I
understand like he's not the person you
can you know be desperate around you so
I probably will just clam up because I'm
not going to try to make someone who
doesn't like fools like me you know
right right I'm probably gonna be pretty
scared I
I'm convinced that I will still be needy
because that never changes no that never
changes but I I will um I'll do some
things that irritate him throughout the
interview on purpose I think probably
yeah just to get him going I'll say I'm
you know I don't think airplanes are
great machines uh I don't think it's a
very I don't I don't think it's a great
design and we should probably just you
know mankind should stop using them what
the hell yeah
I mean I I could so I think that would
be one thing it's like planes yeah you
need to get to a point where you could
just like fly somewhere that's where
we're going right after Chipotle we're
gonna fly from Chipotle to Chipotle and
pick up full Tomatoes you know what you
should do you should convince him just
do a lot of reading that you're an avid
pilot and then become friendly with them
and then take him up and reveal right
after liftoff that you've never done
this before
that's like a scene from Temple of Doom
can you fly no can you
well what what don't do that when he's
here please hang it out now I'm getting
it out no you're there's no getting it
out now getting it out that's like a
pervert saying whoa I just masturbated
once that should take care of problems
well all taken care of for all time I
just shot my load oh can I'm ready to be
a real regular person for the rest of my
lifetime because we all know semen
doesn't regenerate and urges don't
return I'm worried about you now but for
other reasons not about Harrison Ford I
just thought it was two world too real
and that's also in my real speaking
voice I used when
I could go how did you guys think it
went
are you gonna be your usual self yeah
okay I'm look Sona all joking around you
know that I travel in some pretty heady
circles I do okay so what you know I'm
gonna flip out because Harrison Ford's
here no I don't think so I'm gonna be
like hey HF
you know which way is the wind which way
is the wind blowing no
what's up what's up what's up what's up
you don't even do that normally now I'm
worried when he comes in we're all gonna
be trying to play it so cool that like
we're not even gonna speak to him we'll
just talk to ourselves I'm gonna smoke
the whole time yeah I'm just gonna have
a cigarette well no it's gonna be one of
those bubble gum Vapes
it's gonna make a little bubbling sound
and the whole room will smell like
watermelon and bubble gum
let me tell you something Harrison I've
been around
[Music]
um
you like that sound like that you said
one of those watermelon Vapes but I
don't know what you're talking about
well you know that they make
them no I think you're confused oh a
bubble pipe with a watermelon I know
what sounds funny to me so I altered I
essentially altered what an e-cigarette
is what a vape okay what a vape pen is
to match what I think is funny okay so I
bend time and space well now you're
going to make things that aren't in and
of themselves funny okay to create uh
yes in my mind a vape goes
and there's a fruity smell in the room
it isn't just me Harrison Ford is gone
in five minutes guess what I just uh
guess what yeah his publicist just heard
some of this conversation and he's out
yeah it's definitely that's probably
best yeah close yeah she played him two
seconds of us talking about him
that's the right choice I think I think
I think the right choice is for him to
just not come and I think for the team I
should call in sick I really think I
shouldn't be here you know he fled this
uh podcast like a giant boulder was
rolling after him see that I understand
now you're talking what if you have to
pee real bad or poop I'm planning to
wear a diaper all right all right let's
no I meant singing there have been times
when we've interviewed people where I've
had to go to the bathroom really bad and
I'm like sweating here and you guys are
chatting so I'm just saying like what
happens if then that just becomes that
has nothing to do with Harrison Ford
being a cool great booking for us that's
just you needing to use the bathroom
sometimes yeah so that's completely
apropos of nothing I know I'm sorry I
just was I was trying to figure out all
the scenarios okay maybe uh let's let's
get on with the show but HF
hey Chef if you change your mind come
swing on by okay okay
take that baby down that pf-17 550 no
put it on the airstrip see it crack the
cockpit bye grab a whole tomato here we
go
vape pen sound that doesn't really exist